سوف أرتديه فوق
سترتي
لأنه جيب
الجيب المليء بالأمتعة عندما أكون في
رحلة طيران رخيصة ولذلك أقوم باختبار
حيل التعبئة واليوم هو فكرة جيدة
وهذا هو هدفي نوعًا ما  لتسليط الضوء على مدى
سخافة أن ندفع
الكثير من المال إذا أردنا أن نأخذ أي
أمتعة معنا، حصلت على
مكبر صوت جواز السفر الخاص بمجموعة الصالة الرياضية، أما بالنسبة لحيل التعبئة، فقد
قمت ببعض الأشياء الغبية قليلاً،
يمكنك القول أن لدي الكثير من الجيوب  اشتريت
سترة صيد وملأت جميع
الجيوب وهذا بالتأكيد فوز آخر
لعدم دفع ثمن أي أمتعة، لقد
ارتديت حمالة صدر ضخمة
وملأتها،
استخدمت وسادة للرقبة ذات مرة وأخذت
الوسادة خارجها
وحشوها  كانت مليئة ببنطالي، لقد كانت مجرد واحدة من
تلك اللحظات التي تعلق فيها المصباح الكهربائي، وكان ذلك بمثابة
فوز كبير،
جرب هذا
الشكل، ما أفعله موجود على الإنترنت وجزء منه
بالطبع هو للترفيه عن الناس،
لكنك تعرف ما الذي يقومون به بالفعل
حتى الآن، لا يقومون بوزن أي شخص
قبل أن يصعدوا إلى الطائرة، إنهم
ينظرون فقط إلى حقائبك،
وبالتالي إذا كان بإمكانك حزم المزيد من
الأشياء على جسمك، فقد نسيت تقريبًا
البيكيني الخاص بي، فهي بالتأكيد
طريقة جيدة للقيام بذلك  أتمنى لك يومًا سعيدًا،
لا أعلم، أجد أنه من المضحك أنني
أداعب الدب قليلاً وأقول،
انظر إلى هذا الأمر سخيف، وانظر إلى ما
تجعلنا نفعله للحصول على أغراضنا في
هذه الرحلة